les premières familles à pénétrer dans
le parc de loisirs ce matin un couple de
commerçants de villepinte et leur fils
de 8 ans ils sont dorénavant l'inviter à
vie au royaume de disney robert papin la
casquette jusqu'aux oreilles de mickey
la course au passeport d'euro disney est
ouverte
une seule famille sera élu
le petit gorka peut être fier de ses
parents la famille gallier en achetant
le tout premier ticket d'accès au parc
est en même temps entré dans la légende
disney il habite villepinte en
seine-saint-denis
ils ont tout juste la quarantaine l'ec
alliés travaillent tous les deux dans le
prêt à porter à destination des états
unis et il jure que ce n'est que le
fruit du hasard
ils étaient déjà nombreux ce matin à
rêver de franchir les premiers les
portes du rêve
certains n'ont pas hésité à dormir toute
la nuit dans leur voiture
ils sont venus de toute l'europe et
parfois de beaucoup plus loin
la famille gallier n'a eu que quelques
kilomètres à parcourir
euro disney land sera désormais leur
résidence secondaire
ils pourront y rester toute leur vie
s'ils le souhaitent mais trois jours
suffisent pour profiter des 29,4 à sion
en attendant gorka rêve dans les bras de
son héros préféré